welcome to bafta film craft the sessions
it's a series of talks with BAFTA
nominees looking at the craft that goes
into the many films that have been
nominated in the first session today
we're going to be looking at the role of
sang and Craig and Thomas E in many ways
whiplashes is the roller coaster ride of
the entries in terms of the history
behind it yeah I initially got the call
from the assistant director he was a
friend of mine and I was excited to get
a new job you know he calls and says hey
it got this thing for you it's a short
schedule not a lot of money first time
director it's gonna be really
challenging as a great sign me up and so
they sent me the script and that's when
you know it became clear as day that I
had to say yes everybody remember
Lincoln Center and its ilk use these
competitions to decide who they're
interested in and who they're not and I
am NOT going to have my reputation in
that department tarnished by a bunch of
[ __ ] limp dick sour note flattered on
their girlfriends flexible tempo dip
shits got it I'm just curious about the
freedom that you were given to sort of
create this arrow universe Damon was
pretty the director was pretty focused
on what he didn't did not want to have
in the track so we we had some ideas
about stuff that we put up that he
wasn't interested in but for the most
part you know his music was really
another character in this film and we
really had a you know sort of work at
that and the time that we had to get it
to where it need because Damian's a
train jazz drummer he was really on top
of anything all the time the fish snare
wasn't quite right or the Tom wasn't
quite right he was really on top of us
about that so so he was the JK Simmons
he was JK Simmons of yeah there's a lot
of there might have been some Panthro
and if I if my partner Ben door
thing was not quite something wasn't
quite right with the effect side of it
there'd be kind of a lot of jokes about
not my tempo a little little trouble
there and that kind of thing so it was
it was an intense period but we we had a
good collaborative experience with
Damien I would say he was he was open to
our ideas in terms of where to push it
and where to pull it but he was quite
focused on on his idea as well one more
thing Eugene give me that if I ever find
one of these lying around again I swear
to [ __ ] god I will stop being so
polite get the [ __ ] out of my sight
before I demolish you stage right in
order now I can still [ __ ] see you
mini-me auntie I'm curious with some the
actual machine cheering his machine mate
he created the sounds that were created
a random Orton wanted from you guys so I
had already before the phone stand
really got into going to Bletchley and
talk talking to these enthusiasts so
they are very kind of interest in the
machines and I did some temp recordings
just to see what they sounded like but I
realized we'd have to set up a recording
like on an official basis and my kit
with perspective I did consider the
possibilities that we'd like it from
many perspectives so we tried contact
mics on the on machine itself that
exists and then you know variety of
different boom mics of different
positions and so I ended up with a multi
track of what is the existing machine at
Bletchley and they could run it a couple
of times before the public came in so
that was as good as it got but then the
comments would start to flow like needs
to have a bit more feeling about it
actually have a heart the sort of things
you get from producers editors and
directors so I went back to the drawing
board a bit and started to add and take
away things but you know one tries we
always try to do things I like
transitions myself so I'm always looking
for ways of building the soundtrack in a
way which it flows across to the next
scene so if you go from the station into
the Train it there's an archive that
goes across the connection it's just a
hard cut but I wanted the Nazis to be
the same rhythm as the train and it
worked originally with the original
layout temp uzak and then the music
change so it's slightly further back in
the mix now but it's still there you
know it's still there but these are the
things we
we try and put a little bit of flavor
into it and then we put it up the
flagpole and we see if the people who
paying our bills like what we're doing
and say yes maybe and things get taken
out you can't you know you can't really
know that everything you've supplied is
going to work and even isn't difficult
is impossible the Americans the Russians
the French the Germans everyone thinks
enigma is unbreakable good let me try
and we'll know for sure went we just a
general question for all of you I think
the way that people writing on film have
talked about sound has has changed
radically in the last 15 years on my
perception of it is I think the general
public ten years ago might have had a
rough idea what sound design is but not
in the same way that they seem to today
do you feel there's being a sea change
over the course of the last decade
definitely decade and a half I think
sound has changed because of the
technology and obviously we must have
much better quality than we have had in
the past for the guys at the front and
the production sound recordist you know
the amount of time and respect that they
get is not the same as the picture
Department and you know as a sound
designer I'm not are interested in not
just the sound effects and the content
and the transitions and all the
ingredients the storytelling but also
how that production sound recordist is
getting the material because the
performance of the artist is essential
anything well there are actors actually
who I don't know if they have it in
contract or not but you know I got notes
that this and this particular actor
doesn't do two things she doesn't work
very wire and he doesn't loop so now
habs and if he is leading right and you
have to work around and figure it out
how you going to do it because he's not
one of those do things his do very be
very nice to him speak with you but
she's not gonna go do I so there is work
to be done you know outside of San you
have to be very diplomatic you have to
sort of show that you really care about
how the actor sounds because it's true
what you say that the you know it of
course it comes from the director but
that performance of a nap
that you see it's really good you know
it's so precious the act you know
picture picture alone in my opinion
doesn't have a soul the soul is in the
sound you know that's that's it the the
current situation is noise is good and
in fact I think for our silence is like
to an artists is like the white in the
paint pot you know when we can use
silence effectively and storytelling for
sound it does make it more engaging for
the audience and I think playing lots of
music lots of sound effects opening a
movie with a lot of noise you it's
difficult to sort of get engaged I think
you have to take the audience and really
gently and starting with very little
nothing at all maybe one very small
specific sound and she makes the
audience pay attention if you then take
it beyond what they expected in other
words by changing the dynamics greatly
you have an effect over them because
they jump or there's an effect there
this Craig mentioned you know the horror
for format is you know the only way to
do sort of scare on on movies is to pair
everything down take away stuff make it
minimalistic you know drag the audience
in so they get kind of attached to what
they're not hearing and then you just
shake them by you know using the woofer
and all the tools that are allowed two
years unfortunately I didn't have to do
that in an imitation game but it is
basically just stripping it out and it
tends to happen mainly at the
rerecording stage and you know it
becomes a conscious choice but you know
for me you know it's the best thing you
can have in a film is some form of
silence because it's engaging sometimes
in sound effects we can get wrapped up
in making it hyper real and adding a lot
of extra sounds so it's it's really nice
to work on a film like the grand
Budapest where you know it was more
about making it real and really
enhancing what he was trying to get
across in his film and just to have that
confidence to just kind of leave the
page a little blank you know let
something sit for a little bit to set up
the next event you know so um yeah it's
you know you definitely need the balance
of dynamics and rhythms fortunately we
all can I have to wrap up could you
please join me in thanking Olga
today
you
you